it is super bowl weekend rams versus
bangles and you'll see we've got a
studio divided for the big game you may
also be wondering where michelle miller
went well i will tell you she is
squaring off against dana jacobson in
our annual super bowl city showdown we
love this annual tradition here at cbs
mornings on one side we've got dana
jacobson she went to los angeles the
city of angels hometown of my wife katie
tour where the rams enjoy home field
advantage on the other side michelle
visited the bengals home of cincinnati
where fans haven't seen their team in
the big game since 1989 so michelle the
question why you in cincy you an l.a
girl i am an l.a girl i know everything
there is to know about l.a so i wanted
dana to get a little taste but as cold
as it is in cincy right now
it is hot with that 25 year old
quarterback and dana you can bet bingle
spingles fans are going to be saying a
lot uh who day well they are but the
rams are going to do their best to quiet
them and look michelle you said it
you're an la girl it's your hometown so
we can agree the rams take the prize for
bragging rights off the field weather
check food check attractions check so my
goal on this assignment was to make you
jealous
[Music]
now this is the life sunny los angeles
and i'm already getting the vip
treatment scarlett here she's gonna take
me to the best view in hollywood here at
sunset ranch come on sweetie
[Music]
okay dana
it is pretty nippy here in cincy but um
you do know that is not the real
hollywood sign it's a replica
i bet you didn't know that ohio is
considered the mother of presidents
that's because eight u.s presidents are
from here including staunch abolitionist
james a garfield james garfield had one
of the shortest presidencies in u.s
history and look what i found the real
hollywood sign
you know hollywood is all about the
stars but there's more than one way to
see the stars when you're here i'm at
the world famous griffith observatory
southern
california's to the cosmos
that's nice dana but did you know that
the cincinnati observatory is the oldest
public observatory in the country
[Music]
oh yeah well guess who has the world's
shortest railway and i am so excited to
explore the city like they did in la la
land with emma stone and ryan gosling
been there done that isn't it cute
check this out cincinnati has the
largest abandoned subway tunnel system
in the united states
how's the traffic back in l.a dana
traffic are you kidding me who cares it
is february and look at this i've got a
convertible
but i'm glad you've got a subway that
goes nowhere michelle
[Music]
as for tunnels look at this there are 11
miles of tunnels just like this one
below downtown l.a and rumor is they
were even used to smuggle liquor during
prohibition
speaking of liquor i wonder what goes
well with
a french dip sandwich don't mind if i do
it was invented in 1918 right here at
philippe
or
was it invented six months earlier here
at kohl's
yep been there too
but there's no debating the popularity
here in cincy of skyline chili
in fact
cincinnatians eat more than 2 million
pounds of chili every year just ask
store owner mike mislef you got anything
vegetarian
and you have cincinnati to thank for the
nation's first professional fire
department established in 1853
who dat
we're the bengals not the saints
thanks to la
we have the modern version of the hula
hoop
oh pretty good and the frisbee catch
michelle
why chase around a plastic disc all day
when you can toss bean bags in what is
considered the cornhole capital of the
world
[Music]
we've got the largest toy manufacturer
in the world i've got my barbie michelle
i'm going to get you an anchor barbie
turns out we also have cincinnati to
thank for many of life's timeless toy
treasures
play-doh was invented here it's where
the first yo-yo was patented and hey
two cincinnatians created the magic 8
ball
will i get dana to move to cincinnati
when pigs fly
lookie look here
lying pigs girlfriend
city of cincinnati had such a big pork
industry they used to call this place
porkopolis
the cincinnati zoo has been called the
world's sexiest zoo because so many
animals have been born here including
some king penguins and these guys
they've already scored
okay we should probably get back to
talking about football and how's this
for karma the first ever super bowl was
held here at the la coliseum and now the
rams are playing in the super bowl in
their new home sofi stadium where come
sunday rams fans like this are ready to
raise the multi-billion dollar roof
the bengals don't have home field
advantage but they've got plenty of
super fans like
jumpers
how you feeling we're feeling great
check out this bengal themed house
right here you're also a magician of the
year here in cincinnati take it just
close it up one two
three four five and one right there
what'd you do it's magic
the great harry houdini lived in this
estate and you know i don't want to brag
but he even used a deep water tank here
to practice his underwater escapes
both of sunday's super bowl quarterbacks
are escape artists in their own right
but only one will have this hollywood
ending and welcome to sophie stadium a
super bowl champion come on
hold on
wait a minute don't you work with
michelle miller yeah
why didn't they send her
[Applause]
michelle you want to review
[Applause]
yeah we got angie to surprise michelle
because she didn't get to go to la and
one more thing i promised you an anchor
barbie well there you go my so i should
show it off here they have anchor
barbies we have our uh we have the dana
and michelle version there you go oh i
like it
i like it i love it the reaction on your
face though when they took your shot i
mean i i like spider from i was like oh
my god because they wouldn't show me the
whole picture that's right we had to
surprise her with angie she didn't know
how did you find her we have our way i'm
a journalist i mean
thank your husband and one of your dear
friends yeah no but by the way i was
fascinated learning about even
cincinnati when i saw your stuff i'm
still going with the weather
you know delightful delightful piece who
produced that piece
my tam orbita
chris spinder and camille douglas also
helped me out
well done well done awesome amazing
amazing